joining us now with Morris Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz and Ohio
congressman my turner congressman gates
I'll start with you this investigation
is getting uglier by the minute it's
more of this investigation comes out in
a drip drip fashion but one of the
problems
congressman gates I have with it is this
Mullah report is appearing more and more
by the day like one big extent that
op-ed we found out this week about the
remember the dr. Nancy Pelosi video we
found that that the transcripts from
true president Trump's lawyer John Dowd
the actual transcripts to a voice Mona
Mike Flynn there were key words missing
in this I mean was mullah writing an
op-ed or doing an investigation what we
continue to see chinks in the armor when
it comes to the molar report and I would
point you to the great work by John
Solomon who frequently appears on this
program who pointed out that Constantine
Coulomb Nick whom all are identified as
an individual connected to Russian
intelligence was actually a source of
the State Department working with our
government and so if Robert Muller
wasn't able to ascertain who was spying
for the Russians and who was collecting
and reporting intelligence to our own
government I think it would call into
question substantial portions of his
work but there are three real levels of
what mr. Durham's doing that are
important the FISA abuses the lies
before courts that should not have
occurred also the illegal leaks your
point about a James Baker really
highlights the extent to which under Jim
Comey's leadership the FBI wasn't
conducting investigations and looking
for the truth they were trying to shape
public opinion and finally and I think
most notably the corrupt origins of this
investigation inside the Obama White
House where we weren't just violating
the rights of our own citizens in our
country we were actually off trying to
pressure our allies like Britain to
collect intelligence on people that we
would have had no ability to do here in
the United States all of that together
spells bad news for the people in the
Obama White House yeah I want to get
back to column Nick but congressman
Turner I'll go to you first on kind of a
related topic here you're up on the hill
obviously I'm not you're seeing what's
going on every day do you sense a tide
is turning feeling up there on the hill
where the Democrats realize that there's
something going on here that there was
clearly this was not a to quote Susan
Rice by the book FBI investigation here
I mean listen your colleagues up there
on the hill or Democrats who may not
agree with them
they're not stupid they have to know
that there were some severe Abner
abnormalities here you think they're
getting worried that this is coming out
it may rebound on them
well damn one of the things I think
they're worried about is the new
authorities that the Attorney General
bar has with respect to declassification
because you remember it's not just these
investigation of the or invent or
origins of the investigations it's also
the American public getting the truth
and getting the actual information
remember when Michael Cohen came to
testify before the Intelligence
Committee which I serve on there were a
number of leaks of how Michael Cohen's
testimony was going to sink the
president and leaks about what was in
his testimony and you know the story
sort of came to a screeching halt the
moment that the transcript was actually
released and people saw what was in it
and I think that's part of the aspect
here that's gonna be really important as
the Inspector General as the Attorney
General they move forward with this
investigation of the origins of this
which I had to live through on through
the Intelligence Committee and they're
certainly gonna find out lay holes in
everyone's stories but they're gonna
release this information to the public
so we could read that themselves and see
that that not only was there no there
there but there was some real misdeeds
done it's very obviously I think clear
to the American public that Comey
clapper Brennan and Baker when they
stand on their television sets now and
are clearly anti-trump bias that that
bias predated their leaving government
it was certainly there when they were
over these agencies that were so
important that were targeted at American
citizens
congressman gates on that point you made
about Constantine Coulomb Nick this is
just really disturbing so we find out in
the Muller report that there are real
sins of omission here that would Muller
inand I don't want to leave Weissman out
of this we should be clear Andy
Weissman's definitely advise
fingerprints are all over this you
brought up the fact that you know that
they damn man afford in the report for
having these discussions with colum Nick
whether they're appropriate or not is up
for you to decide wasn't charged with
anything for those conversations but
columbic was a source for the State
Department in the Obama administration
and then we find out this week as well
that one of Muller's confidential
informants in the case it's an
allegation of course but apparently was
arrested for child pornography of all
things
this was Muller source I mean this
report is getting uglier by the minute
and it continues to try
where if there's information that's not
damaging to the president you get these
deep state actors to try to keep that
information away from the public view so
again you see that in the Mahler report
where the kalimba confirm a chinois in
an accurate light but even before then
in the fraud that occurred before a
secret court with no defense attorney
present you had the Department of
Justice and the FBI presenting
information that seemed to indicate that
George papadopolis was off colluding
with Russians when the reality is they
had a transcript where the the Brits had
run intel against Papadopoulos and
Papadopoulos denied ever having engaged
in these unlawful acts and so they're
presenting information to try to
reinforce their bias rather than putting
forward the information that would have
spared our country from this 22 months
of division because from the very
beginning it was obvious to people that
there wasn't collusion but yet they
allowed the investigation to persist a
congressman Turner so we've seen some
informations come out but we've seen
very little accountability I'm trying to
think of the best way to phrase this and
I get emails a lot from people from
listeners and I see him on Twitter all
the time as well they're upset they see
people getting off there's an allegation
this week of a senior FBI official
accused of leaking of course the DOJ
didn't want to prosecute that case why
does it appear that anytime it involves
a Trump associated person Mike Flynn
George papadopolis Paul Manafort that
the heavy hand of Justice comes down on
him hard early morning raids severe
prison sentences Paul Manafort
ridiculously is in solitary confinement
in Rikers Island I was a cop in the NYPD
you don't want to be in Rikers Island no
less in solitary in Rikers Island yet
when it comes to people involved with
the DOJ where could negatively implicate
a Democrat or someone in the FBI
involved in the spying they seem to get
off are we ever gonna get accountability
well the inequity certainly does seem
very troubling and I can tell you from
the perspective of the Intelligence
Committee and certainly as you're aware
from the Oversight Committee criminal
referrals have been made as a result of
the both inaccurate statements that
people have made lying under oath the I
believe the things that go right to the
heart of the inception of this
investigation but you're right the
people around Donald
Trump were clearly pursued for the
purposes of trying to turn them against
the president and to say things that
turned out not to be true I mean the
Muller investigation found no collusion
they did not conclude they found that
there were no evidence ultimately to
conclude that the President had
committed a crime on obstruction but yet
they put tremendous pressure on the
people around them including ruining
their lives and pursuing them with
criminal prosecution but there are
criminal referrals that have been made
that I think go right to the heart of
people being dishonest that utilizing
their bias and abusing their power and I
think the Attorney General is going to
undertake this and I think the American
public are gonna get answers also I
think we need to change our laws I
understand that I totally get it
that you're not you can't go out and
physically put handcuffs up that's not
your job you're a legislator you can
make the referrals I totally get that
but I think the frustration is you know
is there any pressure that we can put on
the DOJ and people to do their jobs it
seems like these inequities are really -
leading to a real imbalance I mean the
Republic only matters if people have
fidelity to add to it and believe that
that Constitution means something but it
seems to mean something for one side but
mean absolutely nothing to the other
side of the political debate and I guess
my question better phrase is well what
from your side can be done about this
well I think sorry I was just giving a
quick fall to try I'll go to you
congressman gates next could be the last
word my apologies congressman my
understanding you know if you look to it
turned general bars investigation the
inspector general's investigation these
are going to get to the heart of where
their law is broken where their
procedures broken you know clearly
things were not done by the book clear
there was abuses of process we're gonna
get the data and information from which
those investigations can lend themselves
to the criminal prosecutions that are
heart of some of the referrals that
company intelligence committee and the
Government Oversight Committee Thank You
congressman gates I'll give you the last
word on that what do you think can be
done I mean people are really getting
frustrated out there the American people
are sick and tired of a double standard
that seemed to pay the yellow brick road
to exoneration for Hillary Clinton when
there were clearly crimes committed
there while at the same time casting
these aspersions on Donald Trump without
a basis as a result of bias
the only reason why we haven't had
people thrown in jail yet is because
Jeff Sessions did a terrible job as
Attorney General now we've got a real
attorney general mr. Durham's on the
case and the information we have now
seems to indicate that at every level of
this corruption there is going to be
accountability and there's going to be a
restoration of justice and the rule of
law and I can't wait for it
congressman gates congressman Turner
thanks so much really appreciate it
thanks a lot